hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Game of Thrones comic-con preview
they're just gonna explain when
everything is happening who they're
bringing and what to expect from the
panel so here we go there's a bunch of
stuff that's happening beyond the normal
panel like they have the panel with the
actors where they're gonna be talking
about all the big stuff that happened
this season but then there's like a game
of Thrones scavenger hunt that HBO is
doing you go round to a bunch of
different stops your name gets entered
for some trinkets and some prizes it's
not like crazy big but it's still like a
fun thing to do if you don't want to
blow your entire weekend waiting in line
for panels because that's basically what
you have to do to get into some of the
panels now hold the door who the hell
they bring in to comic-con this year so
they're bringing Michael's sapota Nick
he's the person who directed the last
two episodes battle of the bastards
in winds of winter - you know - like the
most biggest epic episodes unfortunately
he's busy next year so he won't be
directing during season seven I know a
bunch of people were bummed about that
but that probably has something to do
with their delayed filming schedule but
they're also bringing bran Hodor Ramsay
Bolton Sansa the waif Varys Miss and I
sir Davos and Samwell so unless there's
some big surprise revealed Kit Harington
Emilia Clarke Lena Headey Nikolaj
coster-waldau they're not coming that
you know presumably they're probably
busy filming other things because
usually HBO does try to bring as much of
the main cast as possible you know but
like I said you like with the director
because the start date for season seven
is gonna be so late this year most of
the other actors are probably busy
filming other projects so that's just
like they're physically not able to come
but as you can see a lot of the focus is
probably gonna be talking about the big
twist with Hodor
people asking Samwell about what he's
going to be doing in the Citadel this
year the actual panel is actually gonna
be a 215 on Friday like this Friday so
up side we have salsa and Ramsay on the
panel so they're probably gonna dig a
little deeper into dark Sansa I know
there's still a lot of questions about
what's gonna be happening with her next
season and it's always fun when you talk
to actors that play Psychopaths like
Ramsay what's going on inside their head
like what were you thinking about during
this scene where you were feeding your
stepmother and your stepbrother to your
hounds like what you know what was going
on
Connally Pihl can talk a little bit
about jumping back and forth two
continents forming alliances for
Daenerys for you know forming like this
new alliance against Queen Cersei they
might even be able to offer a
clarification on the door
ship that you see in Tania's fleet so
like maybe Varys went to door then came
back to marine then they sailed back to
Westeros like where they're gonna make
landfall in Westeros like I didn't gonna
go back to door or do they already have
the Dorne ships that they need and
they're heading up to King's Landing
Samwell at the Citadel - I'm sure he'll
have some fun
talking about what he and Gilly did on
that ship that whole time when he wasn't
busy throwing up probably making another
little Samwell if you know like the show
you know does jumps in time where it
doesn't take that long to sail from one
place to the other really in real life
it would take weeks for them to sail to
the Citadel so they would have had a
whole lot more to do than just sit down
in that cargo hold for a single episode
we'll probably get some clarification on
the Waifs relationship with Arya you
know what was going on with some of the
things that they were mysterious about
like why was Arya just skipping around
when she knew that the faceless men
would come for her but really I think
the most interesting thing is gonna be
listening to Isaac Hempstead right
describe what he sees his brand's powers
now in that big twist with Hodor like
the seeming paradox that he created when
he Ward into Hodor while he was also
going back into the past so I think
they'll probably have some simple
elegant explainer for it like it won't
be quite as complicated as we all think
it is but he has a whole bunch of new
powers that we haven't seen yet like
will see that in season 7 like you saw
the night's king crack the earth do a
whole bunch of other magical things that
bran hasn't done yet he can do all those
things - and then there's a whole bunch
other stuff like the three-eyed Raven
said you won't ever walk again but you
will fly we haven't seen him fly yet so
he'll probably talk a little bit about
that and you know you could probably
speculate about what's gonna be
happening when season 7 picks up but I
don't like the biggest questions now are
like you know like what's happened
because of all the big twists in the
finale Queen Cersei
what's going on with Jon Snow King in
the north as has been the case in past
years I wouldn't expect too many
spoilers about the Future season and I
would have said they'd bring a casting
reel but because you know since we've
been talking about comic-con they've
announced that season 7 is going to have
a much later start they probably haven't
cast a lot of characters there have been
casting announcements for a couple of
child characters for a northern scene
like a really important northern scene
but that's really the only thing that
they've announced and in none of the
characters that they are casting for or
like really really big characters so the
downside I think is that you know
because they haven't confirmed a lot of
things
still like a lot of questions that they
have for the production before they get
started they won't be able to confirm a
premiere date like it's gonna be awhile
before they pick a premiere date for
season seven in HBO typically has a
policy of not publicly acknowledging
exposed like they did post this picture
that seemingly confirms rhaegar
targaryen is Jon Snow's father like that
would be like the most seasoned seven
spoilery type thing that they could
confirm but because most of the actors
on the panel have absolutely nothing to
do with Jon Snow's storyline
I wouldn't expect like most of the stuff
that they talked about to be specific to
their characters and the things that
they did during the season so may you
know maybe they'll talk about some Jon
Snow stuff when they're talking to Isaac
Hempstead right like what about that big
twist you went back and you saw the rest
of the tower of joy what do you think
that Lyanna stark whispered to Ned I
will go ahead and say it's a safe bet
that they're not going to confirm what
was whispered in the tower of joy but
they'll probably talk a little bit about
that scene especially from Brants
perspective I did do a video like the
actors who played Lyanna stark in this
scene talked a little bit about that so
I'll post a link to that in the
description it was it was a lot of fun I
am definitely expecting her to come back
for more flashbacks that take place with
Rhaegar Targaryen earlier in this
timeline but because that's like a
pretty spoiler a thing for them to
confirm I don't think they're gonna be
talking about that too much so let me
know in the comments what do you hope
that they talk about at the Game of
Thrones panel last year's panel was kind
of disappointing like they really didn't
talk about anything but there was the
big Jon Snow twist
he was status unconfirmed everyone was
like is he dead you know we're pretty
sure he's coming back all the book
readers were like oh we're definitely
sure that he's coming back but they
couldn't say anything about it so they
just had to pretend like nobody was
asking the question if you ever wondered
why some of the big Hall H panels don't
take audience questions it's to avoid
situations like that where fans are like
hey so this you know this twist with Jon
Snow
he's very clearly coming back here are
all the clues george RR martin was
clearly seating some big reveal there's
all these other people that have been
resurrected what do you guys think do
you think he's coming back like they
just want to avoid having to answer
questions like that so you know it's not
just Game of Thrones other movies you
know with big spoilery twists try to
avoid stuff like that so it can be kind
of frustrating from an audience
perspective because none of the
questions that they address are
questions that you want to know about
like all the most burning questions are
probably
and involves season 7 season 8 stuff war
for the dawn so just be prepared for
them to not address any of like the
biggest questions that you're wondering
about but whatever they end up doing I
will totally do a video for it they'll
probably bring a blooper reel usually
they bring like a behind-the-scenes
video with them messing up doing funny
things that's kind of like the stand-in
for like a big casting reel so I'm not
expecting a casting reel of this season
that they probably won't finish casting
the season seven actors to way later
this summer so be sure to subscribe to
get everything in like my actual game of
Thrones Comic Con panel video will post
on Friday night but I'll probably do a
Q&A video sometime a couple days before
then and there will be a game of Thrones
Comic Con giveaway going on so actually
that reminds me congratulations to this
week's winner I think there's actually a
winner to announce in this video Tristan
Seymour you win a $20 Amazon gift card
just be sure to private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details so we'll just go
ahead and start a new round right now
all you have to do to enter the giveaway
is just be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video so and I'll start
making like a Comic Con video playlist
so you know like where all the specific
comic-con stuff is posting on my channel
usually the easiest way to find the new
videos that I post is to just go to my
home page like my youtube.com slash
emergency awesome page and just go to
the videos tab that always stacks the
newest videos first so you can find if
there's like a video that you missed if
you're not sure if I posted so no
worries and I will be live-tweeting
Comic Con and posting stuff on Facebook
so these are the links for that so
hopefully you guys have a better idea of
what's happening this week there's gonna
be a whole bunch of other stuff but I'll
be doing other Comic Con preview videos
for Marvel DC stuff there's gonna be
like Suicide Squad they'll be guardians
of the galaxy there'll be flash season 3
like there's a whole bunch of TV and
movie stuff happening from a bunch of
different studios so I'm sure this is
not your guys first Comic Con you guys
know the drill while you guys wait for
my next video to post you can click here
to learn more about what the actors who
played lyanna stark's said about the big
jon snow flashback and you can click
here for all my other Comic Con previews
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you